this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised
the clouds are now starting to come
close to each other I can see that it
can it might be over casting 80 any time
soon here by the western side of the
kruger kruger national park ahjumma game
reserve my name is Sydney former enemy
coast and I am traveling with Craig who
is my camera operator this afternoon we
are going to try by all means and get
you see a lot of interesting animals and
for incase if you need our attention you
can easily follow us on twitter hashtag
safari live you can also follow us on
youtube chat stream so my tracking is
beginning now and when the Sun is very
hot like this it makes it very difficult
for me to estimate the age of tracks but
I will try I'm looking for wasana
specifically this afternoon but you know
nature is unpredictable we can go out
now looking for Sanne specifically and
come across someone else
so I saw hosannas tracks this morning
and they were very much fresh
so anytime soon Mara will be joining us
and they are still busy having just a
little bit of a technical problem and
sorry for apologies for that
inconveniences
so you can hear the wind is blowing too
much by this direction where I'm heading
to now which is towards the tree house
them tree house them is dry at the
moment but for data's they don't want to
go away from it they go and wait they're
still just to see if animals are going
to come and pass by so además they've
got quite a lot of trust on three hours
them how are we hoping for the same
thing we are hoping for the rain to come
at any time here by the western side of
the grid Kruger I've just seen some
tracks here I just want to be sure what
animal was here and also to check maybe
to try and check the size yeah I can see
that there is a leopard here hmm
these tracks they don't look old I can
see these tracks looks very very very
fresh and he went he went somewhere deep
in here so at least now I have got a
clue I just want to try and see if maybe
we can see it from the camera I can see
here I'm gonna get off now and show you
and I'm happy because tracks I'm seeing
are on top of the vehicle checks for
this morning so the possibilities of
finding a leopard they are very much hi
look at that so you can see it was going
that way this is the track so this track
looks very very much fresh so you will
see that if i disturb this track what is
going to happen you can see that the
amount of wind blowing is not yet blown
this track which means this track is
fresh now I just blown some air on it
but look at what is happening God
disappeared
so it means chances for us to see a
leopard in the area are very high
although sightings is not guaranteed
because these animals can hide but I
will try my best and see if we can find
him
right the way I pointed out the tracks
is the area where this
leopards went into the bushes so I'm
just gonna go down three of them and see
if we cannot find everything there then
I'm gonna stretch in this Callie we
might be lucky here
niconico is not easy to find their paths
so the thing is if you find tricks then
at least it can give you a clue that
you're gonna be looking at this area it
just gives you the possibilities not to
the probabilities so but when we are
driving around in the afternoon it's not
only one vehicle so other people can
also check the other different areas so
lepers are not that very easy to find
but if you have seen it in the morning
is when they are easy to find in the
afternoon but if we didn't see it in the
morning then it becomes difficult so
this area is the area where I'm going to
go in and check
the paw print can tell you if is a young
leopard or the old leopard the size of
the track will tell you mostly the young
leopard tracks are very small and the
old leopard chefs are very broad male
and female tracks also don't look the
same female chicks are much thinner and
the male leopards are much broader so
this is the area I saw the tracks coming
in and there's even another road by the
other side if I don't find anything by
this little galley it means I'm gonna
have to proceed and check if this
leopard didn't cross to that side but I
can promise you the chances of us seeing
this leopard they are very much high
because the Sun is very much strong when
the Sun is strong like this it does
ground the activities of these big heads
so they don't really like it walking by
the Sun
chuckling the chances of a leper to
attack a human they are very much high
but here in Juma the lepers they are
still behaving their natural life their
behavior is not modified at all what
modifies the behavior of the animals is
what is happening in the area of
distribution what is happening in the
surrounding matters the most if there is
a lot of animal hunting in the area then
animals tend to be aggressive also if
there is too much translocation and game
capturing it modifies the animals as
well so here we don't have such problems
animals are still having the natural
human fear
so this is the area that tracks I saw
came in there's a little galley again
there I just have to check HERE very
very careful so I can't see the tracks
on the ground but here is lot of green
bushes which can be ideal for this kind
of cats to hide in so the squirrels are
not making any noise and they are my
good friends the Spirit is the one who
normally gives me the updates
the lepers they do like to hang up by
the trees but normally during the day
you will find them lying down in gullies
the gullies are this old dry riverbed
that is where they lack it the most
because those kind of areas are the
areas which are very much moist and
humid is not that hot as outside by the
drainage line there is quite a lot of
green trees because it's where the water
is flowing during the rain there's still
quite a lot of water underground so what
is growing by the drainage line you find
most of green trees so by the trees yes
they do go up mostly when they've got a
kill that is where they hang up
sometimes when a tree is too green and
they need some shade up there they can
go up and and use their spot to blend
with the leaves in order to avoid
detection as well so this leopard came
here
and the lepers they don't live in the
den but don't can confuse where the
lepers are living is also determined by
what is happening at that time for
example if it's a female leopard having
the very cups they can hide their cups
in the den in other words the lepers
when they are still very young when they
are still very young they do stay in the
dance but as they are growing then they
are going to be exposed outside and that
is when you will find them hiding here
under the trees the old lepers they stay
here on the ground they are more
terrestrial than foss Oriole they don't
really go underground for cereal adjust
those animals who stays under the ground
so here I have checked and I didn't see
anything but it does not mean the
leopard is not here I might hear birds
or any other animals giving alarm calls
in the very same area I have checked
this ideal spot helps this health in
order to hide
so but the cats that I am thinking is
the one responsible for the tracks asana
it doesn't really hide away from us when
whenever we are looking for him he's
just natural it just lives the way he
wants and we see him he doesn't have any
potential to hide away from us
Sebastian that is quite a lovely
question the lepers are not identical
yes they can be the lepers coming from
the same gene pool but they are not
identical each one of them has got its
own sports so it's like our fingerprints
they our fingerprints they are not the
same but they look more or less the same
so lepers too is like that it is so very
quite here in terms of the warning
course so the screeners are not even
making any noise as well yeah I saw some
other tracks here let me just verify
yeah the hyenas we're also here and
hyenas they always come after the
sleepers but after oh I've got a strong
I have got a strong I've got a strong
I've got a strong belief that we're
going to find this animal here in this
area
so now I am going to check this road to
see if that six didn't cross to this
side so if the check says cross here it
means how much they have to carry on
much motor side and check this block now
No
the lepers they are much more active
during the during the night but you can
see them during the day you know quite a
lot of records will tell you they are
active between dawn and dusk but if you
come here the practicality you won't see
them much more active adults leopards
are just opportunistic and when they are
sleeping now if anything comes here is
not going to live it he will wake up and
want to catch it so the leopards they
can be active during the day the weather
condition also influence their movements
when it's overcast they can walk around
during the daytime so according to the
tricks I saw they were heading much more
this side so if I don't see any tracks
crossing here it means he might be still
somewhere in there
yeah I am not seeing any tracks yes so
it means I must check this little gali
from up here
pretty the lepers they do get injured by
their paws because of the thorn trees I
have seen that happening you will see
sometimes doing like this and they take
off the thorns there so lepers they are
not like the baboons which can be able
to groom each other and help each other
when they are thorns so they have got to
use their teeth in order to get rid of
those kind of thorns whenever the the
step on it
oh I got that sexy and let me just check
if the tricks are outgoing that side I
think I saw that Rex somewhere there's
some tracks they but it's sex I'm seeing
now this one's they look old
and they are not as fresh as the truck I
saw earlier so let me just drive around
here
on this road and see
so the Chickasaw now I'm not convinced
so I'm still sure that this lever is
stuck behind us
so to make it simple I'm just gonna go
around here
thank you very very much to all the
viewers who are wishing me all the best
on this leopard search I hope we can
find him
already some impalas here I just saw the
impalas here now
and this impalas are hitting much more
twas
[Music]
side of the universe and not a lot of
antelopes has died but the animals that
we have lost that we have seen here it
was quite a few Nuala's so the funeral
has died but it was not like as a result
of the drought
so what kills the animals by this time
of the year is the following by the end
of the dry season or some other people
they call it a drought season the end of
the dry season the animals they go
through quite a lot of stress and stress
like in humans they will cause you
problems such as heart attack and stroke
but here by these animals when they are
stressed they do go through a problem of
myopathy myopathy is kind of a disease
which affects their masters so when they
affected by the maskers they cannot
climb even a very small little hill
because they joints and the Massa
muscles don't support their weight and
you will see the symptoms such as
fatigue and then they've got problems
with a blood transport and that is what
kills the animals so those kind of
knowledge that has been recorded dead
some of them has been taken to the
scientific investigation and the results
confirmed that it was indeed the
myopathy that is why it is this what is
called a captured myopathy a capture
myopathy is also a stress which is posed
by us human
when interfering with the animals during
the game capturing when we are capturing
and translocating animals this kind of
sicknesses which affect the muscles they
do affect animals and animals they die
another thing which causes the mortality
of animals by the end of the dry season
is the nutrition nutrition which is by
the trees which is low and failing to
support the body of the animal to be
strong enough in order to fight cold in
order to fight heat and in order to
fight against the animals chemical
reaction in the form of training which a
point which is a poison
animals use chemical animals used at
least to use to regulate browsing
activities so their bodies by this time
of the year because of a dry season and
not strong enough in order to fight
against simple problems
so now is the time we can now we can now
cross over to the Maasai Mara
where David he is eager to take over
from me at this stage
a very good afternoon everybody and
welcome to our drive from the Mara
triangle in Kenya and we we apologize
for having been not you know online for
few months but all good now my name is
David and with me today is boom gay boom
a good afternoon
welcome everybody and my plans today is
to look for some lions that recall the
role of pride I have not seen them for
quite some time but this could be a good
day for me to look for them because
Steve is not in this area he has gone in
a different direction
alright remember this is a very
interactive Safari that we do so you are
questions comments are very welcome I'm
sure didn't sydney already tell you
using hashtag safari life and that is on
twitter so I'll first swing by the mosh
area and then symporter
sorry I missed that question from Karen
discussed assemble goods there
kalkaryn sorry I missed you Christian
and you're asking is this Africa if
that's your question yes the Mara
triangle Game Reserve is in a country
called Kenya and Kenya is in East Africa
and East Africa is in Africa it's good
question
and cutting the fasting will show you
today will be some baboons and this type
of a boots we call them the olive
baboons and baboons just like primates
just like us
omnivores and they would eat both green
and carnivores green I'm talking about
like they're they could be picking seeds
they could be picking any roots they
could also be picking an insect that
they defined on the way as they walk one
unique thing about the baboons they go
in groups that one has a baby Bungay
very good job on gay sea carrying a
small little baby on the back so it
could be anything they are picking and
as I say they're omnivores
it could be insect like locust
grasshoppers you know any beetles they
get on the way warmth but here out
guests or think they are picking more of
grass seeds than anything else we good
another type of be born in Kenya that's
called a yellow baboon but that's more
of low elevation and drier areas
how nice well raid on the back of that
mother there and that one at the back to
me is so huge and my guess is that might
be a male just yes that is a male by
virtue of his size Allen happy to hear
your name again and you're asking
whether I speak Swahili I'll tell you
what in Kenya or rather in East Africa
the national language of the three
countries of East Africa Kenya Uganda
and Tanzania is so Haley so my national
language is Swahili and I don't know how
much Swahili you know Allen I'll give
you one word for today
and when I say hello to you next time I
am going to say jumbo J a MBO so jumbo
is hello in Swahili which is my national
language I can as well say jumbo to the
baboons there and they move with big
groups that we call a troop so you can
easily see a troop of baboons or if you
want you can also say a Congress of
baboons both males and females as they
move and the monkeys that's a very
intelligent when you see them moving and
the area we come from they come to the
garden and they keep stealing or food
Christine you'd like to know as I move
and leave with the baboons alone are
they aggressive I would say no what
they'll do sometimes see them come into
the campgrounds and when they come
they'll just be looking for food and
they come and browse what that can get
but sometimes when we get people being a
bit careless and not disposing you know
some ways nicely like potato peels of
fruit peel you'll see them going through
the garbage and trying to turn over the
garbage basket and getting some food but
in general they are not aggressive to
people
we have like a loop fence by the camp
and the fence is electric and you'll get
them the lead male which we called alpha
male coming with a stick at they're sick
and pressing the live wire of the camp
and then they all come jumping in and
the last one to come in second last hold
the stick for the other one also to go
in very intelligent out same monkeys as
busy sometimes monkeys are very cheeky
now I got another brother of mine who
got something different from my monkeys
well look at what we found good
afternoon everybody we have found a
beautiful male giraffe pouncing through
the open plains of the Mara triangle you
can tell by the grass at its feet it is
extremely windy good afternoon my name
is Steve I'm joined on camera by big
James and we are at in the wire triangle
and it is windy and blustery and there's
a good chance is going to be animals or
carnivores in there for that matter
moving about so we've decided to come in
towards this scope and bread we're going
to hug this all the way down and see who
we come across along the way but back
over to this beautiful black and white
ostrich a male ostrich indeed don't see
any ladies anywhere nearby we rarely see
them down indra but they are quite a
common occurrence up here in the Mara
primarily due to the habitat being nice
and open such as do fall prey to large
predators such as lion cheetah and
leopard so they need to be able to see
where they're going and what is
approaching them very nice meat ostrich
today introduces says the giraffe I'm
sure said ostrich did I said giraffe
James James doesn't believe I said
giraffe sorry everybody if I did well
it's clearly not a giraffe it is an
ostrich beautiful ostrich with the black
and white plumage so essentially the
reason why males are black and females
are sort of Rufus Lee Brown dusty
colored due to the fact that the male's
essentially incubates the eggs at
nighttime being more camouflaged at
night with the blackness and the females
by a day and they take turns incubating
their eggs which one egg is equivalent
to about 22 or 24 chicken eggs so an
enormous amount of protein and they are
very very well sought after by many an
animal out on the open plains
what ostrich egg would see an animal
doing very very well
rupy ostriches well they they don't mind
being in groups you often find them in
groups but ours here well there's not
actually that many ostriches around to
be honest but essentially ostriches
should be spending a lot of time out in
the open plains and they can't be in
small groups they can be solitary like
this male maybe he doesn't have a lady
but often they are seen with a male and
female and their offspring and The
Offspring can number anywhere from four
to about seven or eight following mum
and dad around they are known as
precocial which means the eggs are laid
very large as I said before lots of
protein in the egg and that gives the
chicks the ability to develop to a much
more established edge and there's no
parental care with regards to feeding
the chicks all hatched at the same time
and then off they all follow mum and dad
so often you'll find a group of them
together every now and again you find
lonely guys are chirp poor thing but in
more favored habitats where the
territory is maybe a little bit better
or the food sources are better you'll
definitely find groups of seven or eight
males trying to attract the attention of
the females
and so on the bird that is completely
given up flight for the ability to walk
and run very very quickly on the ground
the feathers and wings only being used
for insulation the wings for display and
dancing and also as an intimidation when
they run to chase a predator away
they'll lift their eggs out when you one
and a half and they lay eggs well that's
a great question I'm I would assume they
would do it once a year but I could be
wrong being a large bird they don't
really have the time to incubate more
than two clutches a year but maybe in
really good seasons they might be able
to lay more than one set I'll have a
quick little look so essentially they
can lay through after year you can get a
total of 17 legs in one nest which is an
incredible amount but generally
averaging eight to fourteen two to three
or late per day and what happens is
they'll lay the eggs and move away lay
the eggs and move away and only
incubating once all the eggs are laid
and through that period basically all of
the eggs will then hatch at the same
time called synchronistic hatching so
that you get all the babies coming out
at the same time so that the attention
with one chick hatching doesn't attract
the attention of predators to eggs that
haven't yet hatched and they could not
fly regardless of their weight so
they've out done it now they don't have
any barbs on their feathers so
essentially I do apologize to the wind
essentially their feathers are loose if
you've ever had an ostrich feather they
very very useful for feather dusters
they don't have Bob's the barbs are
essentially zips on the feathers which
attach them together almost like a zip
would honor on a bag except all the
feathers or normal birds zip together
and the ostriches have no Barb's at all
so when they flap their wings there's
absolutely no downward pressure given
it's just like flapping a loose cloth
the wind there's no there's no
attachment there's no physical boundary
or barrier pushing down which is
essential for birds to be able to fly
the barbs in the wings it's why birds
will preen regularly cleaning their
feathers and also Ria's upping any
feathers that have come unzipped so as
to provide maximum thrust for when they
fly around so ostriches have given it up
all together and the feathers as I say
are mainly there for insulation and the
male and female for mate recognition oh
yes Annihilator the male's do a very
intricate dance of waving their their
wings around in circles and lowering
their shoulders and really showing off
to the ladies how it's done and well
she's quite picky and if the dance isn't
done to her specifications she will
probably move on and pick a male who's
got some more dance moves or some better
dance moves or maybe as harnessed the
ability to dance even better and maybe a
younger male who really doesn't have
with the rhythm you know not everybody's
got the right rhythm and well ostriches
when they see a man they want him to
have the proper rhythm it's all about
technique and this poor guy
well he's all on his own I'm scanning in
the distance seeing if there maybe is a
female nearby but there's not and you
can tell that being on his own is quite
risky because he gotta lower his head
very low to the ground to feed and each
time he does that he's at risk of being
snuck up upon so hence the fact that
he's constantly raising his head and
alerts awareness very jumpy in the wind
anything could be trying to sneak up
next to him as we speak wouldn't that be
interesting to watch a cheetah coming
out and know it pulling down the smell
because the leopard would really love to
take down an ostrich I'd love to see
what ting gana would do to him but
talking about leopards Sydney is on the
search of the little chief I wonder how
he's getting along still looking for
this leopard here in the area and Steve
was talking about the leopard and
ostrich I have witnessed exciting many
years ago of the leopard catching an
ostrich ostrich is the fastest
two-legged animal on the ground
you can see the squirrel on the ground
the speed almost climb a tree and try to
help me find these leopards when they're
on the ground they're not clear they
cannot see the leopard I'm looking for
so according to the tracks this leopard
is in this block some checking another
area here this road a border just to see
if he has not yet crossed to the private
concession side
the livers and the domestic cats they
are all cats and cats they've got more
or less same kind of behavior so the
levers they sleep more because the
lepers they each bite a lot more than
the domesticus and eating too much needs
to be given a lot of time you have but a
beautiful kuru this is a beautiful good
look at that he's just yeah what a
magnificent could this is a gorgeous
could indeed and it's not even worried
about us here you can see all he's doing
is eating is just getting the fresh
leaves coming from the tree
his body conditioning you can see that
he was getting thin but now it's time
for him to regain again and look much
better those horns are so big look at
that he completed the first second you
can see that is one two three tree
twists
so a1 is consisted of a bone and a
keratin so the black we're seeing on the
outside is the carotene and this is what
creates the difference between the horn
and Aqsa cone for the giraffe giraffe
doesn't have this layer of keratin on
the outside if you look on the face the
cut has got every line this gorgeous
kudu has got AV line on the face
gorgeous good as per the viewers so the
gorgeous scooters got the V line which
is there as an anti polluter strategy so
they can vibrate the scheme here on the
face which there makes the predator when
looking at them think that the cuckoo is
dangerous whereas is not so the Kudus
can be able to jump very high from a
standing position he can jump 2 to 4
meters hyphens and that is too high when
it's running it can easily jump
sometimes they even try to jump over a
vehicle
acosta the horns I'm not too sure about
the weight of these horns but they
cannot that be very heavy I have handled
them before
it's not a very horn it's not a very
heavy horn so these good ones are some
of those there are some of those those
are those are some of those instrument
people were using in order to create
music during the olden days and now
let's cross over back to Steve in the
Maasai Mara
look at what we found in the middle of
the day you can tell the wind is
unbelievable we've got an owl it looks
to be an african grass owl and i think
i'm not a hundred percent sure if
anybody can correct me there.you most
welcome to but it is not enjoying this
wind at all and they're guarded as if it
is the grass out which looks very
familiar to me and it is a very uncommon
resident in southern Africa and a highly
endangered due to the destruction of
their natal grasslands transformed into
either agriculture or or into
residential area as they just live in
the grass this guy trying to find some
shelter in the tree and very very well
it's it's not in the best spot the wind
is blowing him all over the place
how interesting so similar to the servo
that we've spent some time with the
earlier this week this would be a
nocturnal predator of rodents in the
long grass as well as some birds and
maybe some insects that they can catch
they can spend some time walking around
but they do have quite a large wingspan
and that but bowl-like face typical to
the earless hours such as the barn up
the grass out that bowl-like face
actually is able to channel sounds of
anything that are moving around in the
grassland underneath the smallest little
rustle of a mouse on the grass as they
fly over with enormous wings very silent
flight we spoke earlier about the
ostrich not having barbs on the wing so
they can't fly while the owl with theory
there their small body weight to their
enormous wingspan most owls actually
have a reversible zip on the wing on the
feathers which mean that it doesn't
cause that downward friction motion if
you've ever heard a small bird flying
away you can actually gather of the
wings moving now on our because they've
got enormous wings for their body
weights doesn't have that sound because
the wings are very big to enable them to
fly silently and they don't have those
Barb's
to enable that downward forcing pressure
and that together enabled them to have
silent flight and with that bowl on
their face actually channel's the sound
of any movement any moving rustle
towards their ears which are on the
sides of their head and their head
basically has ears that are a different
level on each side so the bird is able
to triangulate the slightest of
movements in the pitch blackness cosider
yes it is very similar to barn owl very
very similar indeed it's just a bit
darker in Calabar Niles a very creamy
but that looks similar with that same
sort of face and the bowl face that they
have and no ears Tufts that you can see
normally when you see hours with what we
call is they're not actually ears their
ear tufts which are mainly designed for
camouflage or also supposedly for mater
recognition but the grass owl doesn't
really need camouflage because it nests
in the ground or on the grass whereas a
barn owl also nests in sort of a cavity
your three owls such as the Giants
spotted and the Scopes those sort of
owls need ear tufts to blend in with the
background it kind of breaks up that
that rounded head but you can actually
see the foot of the owl we've got what
we call Zygo dactyl feet on ours two
toes forward and two toes back and
sydney talking earlier about tracks owls
have got the coolest tracks with
basically a very nice sort of X in the
sand or a K that they leave when they
land
sham song this is number 160 that's
fantastic fantastic to hear put a little
alley is hiding their moments before the
folks I nearly jumped out of my seat
because a peregrine falcon was flying in
the air that was impossible for James to
capture it because it was using this
wind to its advantage to fly around and
really move with some absolute speed and
the hour hiding in the the shade of the
tree trying to avoid the wind the
peregrine falcon harnessing it
Zach I'm not aware of any hours that
Margaret invariably our take on a
nocturnal prey sauce most of it being
rodents and the like so they don't
really need to because there's plenty of
them throughout the year the reason and
the way they've eliminated the need to
Margaret is by evading space or changing
space and time and being active by night
when some of their competitors are not
so hours no need to Margaret that I know
of if anybody knows of an owl that
Margaret's please let me know I've never
heard of it
liam chavez old i have no idea why is
not moving maybe he thinks he's in the
best spot or maybe he's having a proper
sleep
they are normally sleeping in the
daytime you can see the wind is really
pushing him around her around it's not
the most comfortable of positions is it
well that's fantastic just spotted it as
we came around the tree there okay well
it sounds like the runners are really
being out in about the last couple of
days and david seems to found one for
himself this afternoon well another
right over here and this is a black
trainer trying to disappear it's going
to smack him torture now you can see
they're just spraying and oops his big
poop what a timing here and they'll
normally scratch the ground after they
just drop the pool and that is an
indication of marking their territory
and that's very characteristic of most
rhinos and most of the black rhinos as
he disappears there in the thickets and
as might have been mentioned before this
always very shy very secretive of the
two species of rhinos that you got in
africa the black and white always
browsers preferring to remain in bushes
and slowly and surely trying to fade
away not sure why he got like a ring on
his bum he will carefully he go like a
ring that you'd see on water box the
water box that we call the common water
box they have like a white ring on the
bottoms and it's very strange to see
something similar on that rhino that
have slowly actually disappeared in the
orange leaf Croton it's not going very
deep in the thicket
single the edge consumer you're asking
are they strong as they all say rhinos
are very strong and out here in the bush
the two animals Phyllis tried to avoid
either rhinos and buffaloes because they
don't have a very good vision but they
smell very well then rather they hear
very well so you don't want to take a
chance with rhino in my village because
we used to have them not very far from
where I grew we were being told by our
parents if you see a rhino coming on
your way just stand near a tree or just
next or beside the tree and it's going
to charge you full speed and as soon as
you get close to the tree or where you
are just move like two meters away and
it'll just come and bash itself on that
tree and that should hurt it so much and
by the time it is recovering you'll have
taken off very good let's see how are we
gonna do with the big five today because
Sydney in South Africa has found one of
the big five I managed to find Hassan
here after such a very long tracking
asana is here and he seems to be doing
some hunting at the moment I can see
that he is looking at something so I am
going to keep following so that you can
have a better fighting he has been
working deep in the thick bushes so we
had to track and try by all means and
search everywhere until we got lucky to
meet him
so he was right on top of a termite
mound here trying to scan this area to
see far and we have just passed a
pregnant Baker somewhere here so it
might be now looking for a chance as we
have shown you earlier that weather is
getting better I can see that now is
getting overcast and and this is going
to influence this cat to hunt
so I can see that he is looking at
something here now look at that you can
see how he's working and see that look
at that thank you very very much
Vicki for such a lovely comment look at
that you can see that he's looking at
something I cannot see what he's looking
at so I am trying to check here what he
is up to but I am not seeing anything
he's leaving the ground and he's talking
and he doesn't want to make noise you
can see he's using the available cover
and he's sniffing the ground again he's
checking something here from the ground
it's slowly moving in there and this is
I think Bush so I want to see when it
comes out from the thick bush what is it
that is Amy I came out of that thick
bush
sorry he's now watching it from the side
what I'm going to do is that I'm going
to try and pull further a little bit so
that we can see but he is aiming I'm
just gonna drive a little bit and free
will maybe and we might be able to see
what he is looking at
so he's trying to get all the updates
from the ground here and he is looking
everywhere so the animals can be able to
sniff and a good news asana indeed I
didn't copy very well what you're saying
but I can promise you here now husana is
talking something and is using all the
different kinds of senses
estimate looks very hungry so you can
see he's doing hunt during the day that
is telling you now it's not about him
lying down something coming for him to
take he is now out looking for something
to eat so all we are going to do now is
to keep a following until we get a
better sighting we don't want to miss
any action
so now we are going to move again and
see if we can find him nicely
now let's say cross over to the Maasai
Mara
where Steve is having the striped animal
well welcome back we are with sample
plains zebra out in the open plains the
bite is just gorgeous respect the moment
they're a little bit edgy just like that
ostrich but at least they've got some
friends where's windy luck it's a really
really a tough time for most animals
with its pumping is very hard well
eliminate there they set to hearing sped
away can hear the approach of anything
and they know there's a lot and out on
these there's a little bit of animosity
there whoopsie what's good would like to
have seen some zebra well here we go
it managed to find you a nice lahood
there's probably two breeding herd here
but bad number it's quite a large herd
if it was just one stallion but what
does happen from time to time due to the
fact that male zebra will defend their
their consorts against the male line or
against Lions cutoff and they'll
actually turn against the lion and end
up getting killed themselves and what
happens is that they're then leave there
in iya pepper or harem of female alone
and what happens from time to time is
that a man with a group of ladies
himself will just acquire them sort of
take them in under his wing and look
after them as he would some of his own
okay well let's quickly go back down to
the little chief who's on the meat
I am here still following the little
chief of Jummah who is now trying to
stalk the prey at the moment but now I
still can't see what is aiming it has
been long distance he is keep following
and following I can't see what exactly
is following so what I'm doing is just
to keep guided by his interest and the
ears and the concentration
there is looking somewhere far I can see
there is now looking at something which
is very far so the problem is is hunting
and he is hunting moving diagonally much
more towards the private concession so I
hope he's not gonna cross or he will
catch something before he gets to the
border
so he's still going further day he sees
giving himself much time you can see he
doesn't want to hurry anything he's not
very much patient about two three months
ago he was impatient now he's gaining a
lot of experience I can see that he
doesn't want to rush he's taking it easy
it's good a strong belief in himself now
so event I didn't copy your question
nicely this is Hosanna Hosanna is very
popular by the name the little chief is
just about to get three years old next
year February he'll be three years he
still a youngster not responsible of any
territory at the moment so he staying
together in the same area with his
father by the name of King Ghana who is
the territorial holder these two they
interact a lot
so I can see now he is very much settled
but he is looking forward and he is
raising the head up he is not lying down
completely so it means his prey might be
still on a distance
Smith asana is one of those leopard who
lost their mothers while they were still
very young and these cat I can promise
you might have experienced quite a lot
of difficulties that is why he is so
skillful while still very young
so if they lose their mothers while
they're still young leopard they they
can be very much solitary and they've
got to do everything just by themselves
so with the help of the mother they can
stay together with the mother until they
get to 18 to 22 month and that is when
they become independent so but if the
mother dies at the earliest age then it
means he must have to do everything by
himself that is why he has got quite a
lot of confidence in himself because he
has been alone for quite a long time
so now I'm going to throw you back to
the Maasai Mara in few seconds you will
be in Masai Mara to the swapper
all right welcome back and we are
watching some antelopes here let me just
position myself Lesley and tell me
Bungay where to stop keep coming
good O'Reilly look at some huge
antelopes here that we call the top YZ
and the together with another different
species sometimes difficult to see sorry
booger I caught you off guard there but
beautiful lights we got and this reminds
me of the Assessor base that you see in
South Africa or guess their cousins and
to me the system is a little darker than
the top is here the one bitter thing
about the top is if you happened to see
closely inside the ears the ears are so
beautiful they're lined up it looks like
a leaf the inner part of the year and
you see the gray on the legs which makes
them look very unique and like all the
other antelopes the Sesame's have more
uniformity on the colors like the
trapeze because you can see the dark
brown the light brown and they are the
bigger brown you know main brown on the
part of the body and also just like
there will be there will be going for
short grass now let's go to the ground
gazelle
and those are the grant's gazelle and
that one is a female rain very good
question how long does the dry season
last in Kenya let me see we got two
seasons of rainfall here in Kenya we got
the long rains and the short rains now
rain what we expect him to get now sorry
are the short rains which haven't come
through as yet and in the meantime let's
first take your clothes to Sydney
because Sydney got something that could
be going for a hunt or sauna at this
stage is just keeps talking and moving a
little bit further and focus after some
time is doing the same thing and focus
but still I can't see what he's seeing
and none of the animals have spotted him
so far that is going to be disappointed
by the wind the wind is now blowing too
much changing all direction look at that
look at that you can see that this
there's something here that is seeing
and it really doesn't want to get
spotted you can see how he's talking and
how it's going close to the ground
I can't see what is fascinating this cat
at the moment and it's using the cover
right in front of him you can see
there's some bushes there those are the
bushes is using and what is looking at
is much more on the left but now he's
concentrating on the right
NW indeed asana is so handsome look at
that look at the colors they in the back
going up the Roses rosettes
he looks like too many flowers rose
flowers you see it's a cane going
further but you cannot see where his
target is at this stage I'm not going to
move at all because I can see the
opening in front that if there's
anything we'll be able to enjoy the
sighting from here I am checking
everywhere and he's raising the head up
but I can't see where is Amos you see
these cars has got this cat's date in
Ghana Hasan and all other predators
their eyes are high up on top which is
their suitable for stalking because when
the head is lowered they can still see
and maintain focus and when it's raising
the neck then is West they can see very
well and they can aim very nicely
Nancy the tail is not as long as it is
the tail is just about ninety four two
hundred centimeters so it's not that
very long so that tail you are talking
about is the tail which will tell you a
lot about the internal mood of an animal
and is therefore the nonverbal
communication look at that you can see
that he is not working as usual now that
is a hunting move maybe is aiming at
something smaller the scrubland I can't
see what is aiming at but now you can
see this coming behind the bush again
and but still focus is much more towards
the eastern side so the focus is on the
left it might take time until we see
what is aiming at he might win this hand
or not predators they are gifted with
the predator strategies and the prey
animals those who get caught they are
also equipped with a good sense of smell
and hearing
so it's not like when the predator is
the hunting it means he's going to win
you can see now he's coming in between
the trees niconico asana now the wind is
on his favour the wind is blowing
towards us and we are at the direction
where he's coming from so the wind is on
this very versus that wind is not
guaranteed can change at any time so it
seems like he's using the advantage of
the wind at the moment and the trees are
making noise the leaves who are coming
out or making noise and also the dry
branches the chances for him to get
closer and closer we're not yet they are
very much high you can see that it
hasn't went it doesn't want to raise the
head you see look at how it's moving he
doesn't want to raise the head and then
again a sitting there I am trying by all
means but I can't see who I was gonna
show you what he is aiming at but now I
can't because I cannot even see what he
is aiming at until I find out I will
show you
so all we've got to do now is to enjoy
his strategies you can see that he
doesn't want to even yawn that be it was
a quickie on so now he's he's up to
something he doesn't were too young
sorry the animals can be able to detect
quite a lot of things in the air you are
right when the wind is blowing it can be
able to pick up air particles and from
the air particles if you know very well
about the presence of the animal and the
presence of other animals of the same
species including their territorial
status
so he came through the bushes now is by
the open space still concentrating he is
now grooming himself a little bit is
also checking everywhere so now it looks
like he is looking for something a beast
listening it looks like an animal who
doesn't know what he's looking for who
is just going with the wind to check who
is coming and where is the smell coming
from when he started his hunt it was
convincing that is the target right
somewhere in front but now he is sitting
is difficult to tell if there is a
target or he picked up just something
from the air particles and is trying to
get closer
Romario
the leopards can go up to approximately
62 94 km/h and that is too fast but the
thing is you will never see us on
chasing an animal for quite a long
distance when the cat such as leopard or
sauna when they're hunting they use a
strategy which is called a sit and wait
strategy it's a sit and wait for data
some other people they refer it as an
ambush predator he will go and get
closer until he get to 5 meters less
than 10 meters to 5 meters is when is
gonna launch a surprise attack and
attack something these ones they use
energy to drag something up into a tree
and they use energy to kill because
everything is happening just by himself
nobody's there to assist him if it
doesn't conserve energy Highness will
come and he will lose the kill he must
be able to drag something heavy up into
a tree
you can see now the movement is not the
same as previous now he is very high up
when he got there he was going very low
but now he's high up now he's just
walking normally so it means maybe
something happened to his target
maybe the target moved to the wrong
direction and now he's deciding to just
keep going forward so I'm still going to
check and we'll be following him I want
to see if there will be any and kill
this afternoon I want to witness that
Jonathan and that is one of the
challenges in the bush you get guided by
what the prey is doing so you don't
decide when the prey is feeding going
this way you have to change direction
when the prey is going that way you must
change direction when the prey is trying
to check if something is coming you must
have to go down and hide
so now my friend David by the Maasai
Mara is also out on a drive Wow we have
come to a place where a sighting of
three different species at the same time
and let's see the best Bungay can do
because we got let's start with the
baboon's we also got elephants and
viewers who got
what does we got urban gave Andes where
have you been else the whole day
buffaloes
excellent so we got two of the big five
here sorry there's a car behind there
and they are also enjoying this sighting
just like us the Boone's could be the
most likely the baboon's we saw earlier
the only of baboons I look at how
peaceful this setting is that everybody
have you know his or her own space
enough to eat but boots come on Hanah
yes they are common but it will depend
on where you are and what you're doing
this particular species here Oliver out
see they are all over East Africa and
when you go further down to South Africa
you'll see a different species
that's called Chacma baboon this one's
here Anna
I could Oliver boot and you can see one
of that guy he is so huge and the
difference between the two that you see
there the one I guess Andre right of
your screen should be a male melt in
general are bigger in size now just look
at that beautiful sighting of the boots
and buffaloes and elephants together
this gives me lots of joy in my walk
that could just come and sit and watch
these different species here without you
know interfering with each other and and
in the final controller says this is
pretty awesome
and this makes Africa a very special
destination for people to visit and
remember this is a very interactive
Safari we are doing should you have any
questions or comments please send them
through hashtag safari live on Twitter
discuss gonna clear the way sorry about
that
and then we shall own these elephants
and baboons and the Buffaloes so that's
buffalo that I think is a boy and by
coincidence the male or the baboon they
also I figure the boy I'm going to try
to put no see the Buffalo is full of mud
and there's a heron following the
Buffalo this is very exciting that could
be the black head heron and what she'd
be doing as the Buffalo walks he
disturbs some grass and the Heron will
be jumping at those invertebrates be
they you know some type of insect hi the
locusts for grasshoppers is the behavior
also done by some bars we call the
egrets she decides just to keep going
and just chance on maybe they would be
busy buffalo that's moving around in the
grass huge male elephant the background
there
nice nice now we got rhinos we got
buffaloes we've got Hosanna elephants
for the big five let's find out what's
remaining and let's go back across to
Sydney I have got an interesting animal
at the moment and this animal if you
look at him now he is right aiming at
something look at the look at it he's
going down he's not chasing he's just
going down and his movie is moving that
fast and he was looking at something
much more that side so I can see that is
going much more towards the western side
we are really battling to see what this
cat is aiming it I can see now he has
again going down how he's going there in
between the classes so he's going down a
very slow paced and you can see him
bending the front legs and how he is
going down that he is up to something so
it's just a continuation of what he was
looking for is keep getting closer maybe
now is when we will be able to see what
is it giving him this kind of an
interest
so it looks like niconico the movement
of the leopard sails they have got quite
a lot of interpretation let me tell you
something interesting which happened
while I was following a tündi about a
month ago
Tandi came across the two scrubbers on
different areas the first cup head was
behind the bushes and tanta wanted to
get this grabbed way of the bushes and
she aimed the scrub where she shaved the
floor with the tail to make noise for
this crab weight to fit it up and run so
the disturb we can run to the open space
for China to catch it's just that she
was not lucky to catch that scrub here
so that tail it can be used for a lot of
things so I don't think we've got a
we've got a visual anymore so what I'm
going to do now is I'm going to slowly
slowly approach and see what is up to
can't even see ye said the moment but I
saw he went up this way
they just got disappeared somewhere here
oh he's right on top of the termite
mound I can see now his right day on top
of the termite mound still looking
towards the same direction look at that
you can see that this animal is looking
at is not close if he's raising that
high it means he wants to have a better
visual is not close to avoid detection
he lowers the head down when that animal
is doing something he lowers
they head down so even if I don't see
the animal I can see that the animal has
got a chance to spot him that's why he's
being down all the time and it's not
even bothered no squealers nothing is
letting everybody about his presence
look at that he went to the back of the
termite mound and now I'm left with no
option but to keep following that we can
see what's happening behind the termite
mounds
he's still moving forward he's not
running
DeLonge the lepers they don't give up
easily they only give up if they have
been spotted so this hunt it can take
very long if the animal in front is
going slowly and it's not even picking
up his present behind he is gonna keep
following following until you get a
chance but if the animal spots him he
give is gonna give up immediately
so it looks like he's following
something here in this area
but you can see now that he's still
moving forward and with the head up
these can see skiing down his gang up
his game down
so maybe they pray somewhere here here
is not much more open so he stick a
little bit here so it won't be easy for
us to see everything so I'm just going
to pull forward again and see if we can
have a good sighting this is exciting
so this is lovely I'm really enjoying
having him doing this - he's using the
termite mound as a cover and he's using
the termite mound as an observation post
during this hunt you can see that
available cover is needed for hunting
you need available cover I think this is
quite a lot of prey animals where he is
arena indeed it is interesting seeing
that there are no alarm calls here maybe
is because animals are not yet away of
his presence he's taking his time maybe
that is why he is not rushing but it
looks like these other animals here who
are also catching his attention because
he's not only focusing ahead is also
checking much more to the right there
must be other praise as well in the area
DeLonge I didn't copy your question very
well
DeLonge the possibilities of asana to
pick up the scent of another leopard the
modern hundred percent hundred and
twenty percent because that is how they
detect each other in the torture when
the wind is blowing the wind blows with
the sense and the scent is the one which
will let him know that there is another
leopard moving or this ascent mark which
is old or fresh the descent mark can
last for about approximately three
months the fresh scent marks they know
they can tell that this has been done
recently and this animal is about there
two and half years old and this animal
is aggressive this animal is good good
gene for reproduction from just sensing
this man they know that the animal
coming is violent or not
so there's a part of the artifactory
communication is a communication amongst
these animals which is from the
secretion of various skin glands
including urine and droppings
so you can see that now he's settled he
is taking his time he is not a now again
is going low so now we are going to
quickly cross over to David but if there
is any developments here we will come
back soon well Sid hopefully Hosanna is
going to do something but in the
meantime we have found a feathered
friend on top of a dry tree and this is
a marabou stock and see how tall these
bodies it was his thing long legs to
support her body and you can tell how
the wind is picking up and blowing and
she is doing the best you can to get
stay still and not be blown away by the
wind
I think this wind is what will be
bringing us some rain late in the day or
tonight you can see how long beak which
it will use when they are filling or
sometimes when they are fighting it's
pretty sharp and very strong you may not
be seeing very well but you look
carefully the legs look quite and
apparently not what in colour is because
when they drop the poo it's always like
you know learning over their legs and
the whiteness there keeps them cool
training herself
not far from where she is there's an
area that has a well because they either
scavenge or you'll get them in water
areas have been looking for something to
feed trying to balance by lifting one
leg up good job
we have always talked of the big five
and sometimes I was talked of the ugly
five and mirabile is one of them that
yes and I agree with you that's pretty
beautiful and Zach if you look carefully
he got a low suck right below the neck
and when the in what we call breeding
plumage Zach
that sucks wasps and it's bright bright
red and she's used always to excite or
the females or for them to look very
colorful and the male's will be able you
know to choose or the gas or the females
will get the males to meet with some of
the tallest stocks that I know another
similar one to be the Sun ability stock
but the marabou is quite tall how she
became one of the ugly five I do not
know because to me she doesn't look very
ugly she got also a bald head like the
vultures Julia as most of the vultures
got bald heads because when they
scavenge or when they eat anything left
behind by the predators they may not get
as much blood on the feathers that would
be on their heads like egos which most
likely would make them sick
tears from a dream yes I would agree
with you not ugly and it looks different
I do not know what to be ugly out here
and I'm talking over the other for that
people call the ugly five you also got
hyenas and what hogs the world chars and
the wildebeest I would agree with you
she's a dream that none of these animals
is ugly but they are all different
that's a good way to put it
I'll be telling all my friends and
colleagues that we do not have anything
that's the ugly five or you know the
beautiful five but you can say all these
animals are different in their own way
so you're gonna be having this Miraval
stalks resting there and we couldn't
move on and find out if we could be
lucky to see some lions before it gets a
bit dark
a friend of mine had told me that seen
lions around this area and I'm not
seeing any sign of rain lions here but
if they're laying flat in the grass
could be very difficult to spot them at
the moment just chanting and crossing my
fingers that I see one popping its head
up because it has cooled off now and
this is the hour when the rollers rise
and start moving because not swarm and
maybe start making plans of getting
themselves some dinner with all the
wildebeest go now we'd be looking for a
different prey or bigger prey let me
just turn around like either buffaloes
like what we just saw a few months ago
or giraffes maybe or Elance Quentin gets
very difficult you'll see even Lions
hunting even hippopotamus I mean they
don't take anything for granted
they'll have to survive come on Willa
what happened there and seen the
wildebeest should come back to the next
migration
Steve had an ostrich earlier they even
go for ostriches
okay put on my massage hookah on because
I believe the temperatures must be less
than 15 degrees centigrade and I would
also think there must be less than 60
degrees Fahrenheit at the moment so I
got trillions
Toula again thank you very much you love
the green and I think is beautiful and
thank you for that great comment and
Paula I might also show you something
different
apart from my green shoe car I also got
some very nice boots you see that I'm
not sure the green massage suka matches
with my zebra boots or not but I think I
got you saw my Shukra in the morning and
I just wanted to know you to know I got
something else on my feets I haven't
seen any zebras today I should get some
zebras and compare my bush to the zebras
and find out whether my zebras my zebra
boots are males or females
Lions Lions Roya could you be hiding we
need to see you before it gets duck and
we shall be completing our history of
the big five and you're gonna make a
sundae thank you very much you all love
my boots and any day that will end
without missing the zebras I'll feel a
bit sad and I still have a lot of time
to search for the zebras I saw as I also
searched for the Lions
the last my friends to the light years
for this particular area here but if it
gets cold and the de sage tags
themselves like that because of the
coldness chances are I will miss them
but it's not very cold for them because
they got better far and they rise up
we'll definitely see them so cross
fingers with me that we see some kitty
cats in this area which the grass is not
very high I have no reason to see them
very good let's all cross fingers and
let's go back to South Africa to Sydney
we have got a sauna now just in a little
bit of a thick bushes they're still
aiming at something and since you have
been to the Masai Mara he has been in
that bush it seems like now he might be
getting closer to what he's looking for
he is appearing for the first time out
there since you have been by the Maasai
Mara so it was just they hiding from the
prey that he's targeting a prey that we
cannot see I can see that now again is
going towards the next termite mound so
this animal is using the termite mound
as a cover every time and the
observation post as I indicated area you
can see is not ending now is aiming
another tomato and so it means from a
termite mound he aims the second termite
mound said termite mound just like that
and please don't get surprised there are
some other vehicles coming to join me at
the moment
pashya the Lepus territory can be very
big but here we are talking about a
territory which belongs to King Ghana
which can be about 20 kilometers square
so the territory of Leopard can go 20
kilometers square more or less Astana is
not yet a territorial holder he is just
within someone's territory
so the territory for this leopard liked
in Ghana they they don't only stay in a
game reserve like Juma alone
they trespass the borders we have got
only works to us to this animals that
don't work Francis has been taken down
and they can be able to access the other
private areas
so let's hope is gonna get something to
eat here he is still looking at
something and I'm just going to now move
a little bit afraid so that we don't see
we don't get obstructed by the other
vehicle who are also looking for a
sightings from Ghana now look for a
better spot again
there's a lot of artifact holes here so
I don't want to get stuck again these
artifacts can dig very deep on the
ground and here on top we don't see we
just see the entrance hole and not
seeing that this hole is very long and
you might sink in there so it's just
left with couple of
until I didn't copy a question very well
because of the wind here where I am but
maybe it is a safe to be in an open
vehicle something you must have to take
into consideration is that animals when
you are by the vehicle open vehicles
they cannot see you they only if you
stand up there you break the shape of
the vehicle then they will spot
something or if you move your hands
rapidly that is when they will be able
to see that rapid action that there is
something there you just have to take it
easy and do everything slow don't stand
if you stand you will be breaking the
shape of the vehicle and it's when there
will be inquisitive so you can see that
on top of that termite mound he looks so
beautiful he's such a beautiful cat look
at the necklace
I haven't seen his kid for quite a long
time so even if he doesn't win now I can
promise you tomorrow morning we'll be
hearing that he got something somewhere
so it's completely overcast at the
moment so which is something influencing
is hunting contacts if you look at that
this is quite look at that you can see
when he is opening the the mouth when
his yearning is when you can see that
necklace nicely you can see that is
breathing so fast as if is a tired
animal look at the pink nose when it
gets eight years old nine years that
pink is gonna get disappear and it's
just going to remain black day
so you can see that I can see I can see
that this is a lovely position and good
to all the viewers who are taking the
screenshots at the moment so you can see
that the leopard wins hunting if by any
chance he gets spotted he give up it
doesn't want to lose energy for nothing
so I can see is yearning all the time so
yearning makes the animals it makes
these animals to improve the mental
efficiency so an is yawning like this is
when is going to be very much alleged
MK is get very big teeth which can go up
to eight millimeters that is that is the
quad eight ten millimeters that is very
long so those are the most important
tool for this animal to kill a prey
they've got to pin those very long teeth
by the neck here and kill an animal
sometimes
so now let's cross over the Maasai Mara
where David is waiting to show you
something
well my Lions have become elusive but
I'm very happy that Sidney still holding
Hosanna Hosanna was my very first layer
that is so when I went into German South
Africa and I couldn't believe I'm sure
you've seen how those cards are designed
they don't even have you know any doors
and husana was ble out see two meters
away from where I was and I thought that
was very exciting what I found out the
leopards in East Africa and the leprous
in South Africa well they're all the
same same species same everything but
the ones here are more skittish not
aggressive but the average has used
maybe to the cars and to people just
like the ones I would say in Douma here
you'll see a little punch you'll touch
your car you could be the only one of
that sighting a second car comes a
father comes and that lever just comes
so climbs down the tree and it just
disappears and very unusual or almost
impossible to see the lepers in East
Africa like on the grass like here are
like 10 meters away from the car I would
say I have never seen that we'll always
see them on top of trees but should you
see them on the grass is when they are
walking and the towards the bush or away
from the bush some giving up now on my
such for clients and be looking for
anything else that MIT
who could meet some ma-maybe leopard
walking on the way
time for the hyenas to come out and
start laughing cackling Jacques this is
a good time for them to be out let me
see who else I was thinking of but she
at Fox will be surprised to see about
about shi'ite Fox out as darkness come
we have animals that will always check
out definitely cheetahs are gone by now
they also move at night but not like the
lions leopards all the hyenas
they tend to be more active or more
alive during the day than at night most
bats allows to be checking out and will
be having a few hours outs we'll be
talking also of some night jars
what else water thick me because it is
bouncer to be coming out he falls as
much as they advance they'll only come
out of water at night to fit spending
the better part of the day in water will
be driving very close to the Mara River
later today and see if you're going to
meet them coming out
Annamarie how are you you like to see a
salvo cart I guessed and cross fingers
and several cats who knows to be coming
out like now we have a family that were
supported by Steve the other day and it
had some Cubs I'm not sure how many you
are maybe about five not sure over the
anna-marie you saw that and if you did
you're very lucky if not we are trying
to find out if they have a den or a
nearly that you can keep visiting them
we found out definitely a dane full
liberty fox and yeah and I am just
confirmed to me they got two cabs this
hour got twists pretty exciting and we
have always seen the adults you know one
they're always very solitary the summer
cuts you really see to anna-marie or one
at a time
but to see one with two cups that was a
very special setting we have vaguely an
idea where they are staying and what you
need to do is to keep visiting that area
and maybe we confirm for a fact that's
where they leave and will always be
coming and chancing and sneaking and
hoping they will come out for us to see
them
the bat-eared Fox definitely via dine is
confirmed which is pretty good you see
something interesting there and I
thought boom gay had seen some nice and
more but not much but he just looked he
was very hard engaged my camera operator
tonight
all righty Liars where are you
and if food system lies now that we just
like in the middle of the road just
walking and they like following the
roads because it's clear they can see
easily where they're going and we know
where they're coming from
- just switched on my lights on because
getting duck but should we come to some
nice sighting we are going to use our
infrared and [ __ ] looks a bit stuck here
to most of you unlike Sydney where he is
because in Kenya we are one hour ahead
of South Africa so that translate to us
or to this area getting duck much
earlier than it is in South Africa
thank you to the technology of infrared
and we can only see the animals without
interfering or in fronting their
behavior and we are already in infrared
at the moment hopefully going to see
something interesting to make a stop and
show Bungay is magic of infrared so many
bars that see I'm seeing on the road but
every time I'm sure we stop to have a
look at them they're gonna fly away the
birds that may not go away now are like
mountain jars this will tend to stick on
the road and what does water thickness
will stick on the road hours
like the marsh the marsh owl and in
finer control tells me also in South
Africa it's getting dark and Sydney also
might be in infrared I'm seeing some
elephants coming up maybe another three
minutes which would be something good
watch very graceful animals so long as
you do not surprise most of these
animals it's always safe to go as close
as you can you just keep your voices
slow switch off your engine don't have a
lot of body movement and we'll just
watch them us they gross a heart of
elephants from counting one two three
four five and six elephants feeding like
the whole day
Marissa how are you have I ever been in
a stampede I'm not sure what Stampede
you're talking about Melissa but I have
been many times in a stampede of
wildebeest not elephants you do not want
Melissa to be in a stampede of elephants
it could be a bit dangerous now let's
look at this Elly's here to the left
because we got five there so a stampede
Melissa of elephants I've seen many time
I mean of will which I've seen many
times but I've always come out safe do
you want one on the right Durbin game I
think the much closer okay Melissa
hopefully we don't get a stampede here
with this Ellis and as I said earlier so
long as you approach them quietly and so
long as they can see you it's always
fine the challenge comes when you sneak
on them or you Surprise them and things
will sometimes go wrong as it is now we
can see yes we made sure this was before
we got here and they have ideally
welcomed us to their world of feeding
now you do notice we are in infrared
that's why the elephant might look black
and white in a way create technology
where we do not shine any artificial
light to this graceful and big mammals
and again remember this is a very
interactive Safari we get lots of joy
when we get questions from you or
comments which you may send through
using hashtag Safari live Bungay did you
want to move the elephants on the Left
how close are they let's see how well
you can do that very good because this
one's here they got some calves with
them
I can just hear them approaching the
grass from the ground it's one in the
same HUD and herds of elephants would be
anything from 2 200 proud cat mama a
very big jumbo from the Mara triangle in
Kenya and yes beautiful alleys and how
you know graceful proud crouch mama they
are just fitting there without being
worried by our presence Ellie's are
intelligent animals and I'm sure proud
cow
forgot mom I know the other viewers
you've heard me say many times they are
my favorite animals because of their
high level of intelligence it's big mama
going there I concealed female not sure
she's big in size or she is pregnant
you can see how mammary glands as she
walks and the only big animals some of
the animals that will always have the
mammary glands between the front legs
and sorry ladies and gentlemen Steve is
having an issue debate with his camera
you might not see him for the next few
minutes as he is trying to rock out and
fix his technical problem with the
camera so just me and Sydney who'll keep
entertaining you and showing you is
before African wilderness
I won't just move a little bit forward
and see the structure you're asking
whether elephants got good night vision
I would say yes I mean this beast will
keep feeding the whole night and
definitely they see what they are
protein they see where they are going
and they see the trees or berries of
fruit or Lisa they're eating I would say
they have very good night vision of
course maybe not seeing things in colors
but I would say seen things you know
dark shades and light shades I did have
some good night vision Bungay let me
just move forward a little bit and see
whether you can see the ones on the
right
a little better it's pretty close to the
road and if I just move a few meters and
we might be able to see his forehead he
doesn't look very concerned because
which is pretty good and how is that
Bungay good good good for you okay
look at
and there they are and you can see they
look to me like two young bulls keep
watching them finding out whether the
right to do something but in the
meantime let's go back to South Africa
and see what asana could be doing so
asana is now somewhere in this thick
bushes and they were somewhat rocks
going in there early on I can see now is
keep going in the bushes going down that
side so what I'm going to do is I am
going to say if we can go to that area
and have a better visual the Warhawks
went very close to him I don't know what
happened there they just passed by very
close to Osama and I thought that was
gonna be his chance to have something
for tonight
it was quite a big family I think there
were about four warthogs
so I'm just going to go around here and
right to the spot where I have last seen
him heading
so he just got disappeared somewhere and
both the whole sauna and the war talks
they got in here oh the hyena is there
as well
now the hyena has arrived the hyena can
smell that something is going to happen
here I can see their eye now is now
behind at the moment so this is maybe
can be about to snare the leopard I can
see that the leopard is not comfortable
with the INA following you will see you
will see it now you will see that the
leopard is here and the ayah is here and
this rayna's keep following and they the
leopard you can see the leopard on the
other side on the right so this leopard
is hunting and the INA presented himself
now if the leopard catches there will be
a drama here so you can see that is not
a tree with its residence of the in at
the moment
so they are you know will also now spoil
the chances of this cat to take
something so the hyena is now moving
away from Osama in the moment asana is
just now lying down there maybe this
might be the end of him hunting or he
might still hit it on hunting so I'm
just gonna pull forward a little bit so
that you can see him
so you can see that now it's nice and
clear he's just lying down there but the
hunting interest is still there you can
see the movement of the head and the
ears concentration is telling us now he
has not yet given up he still want to
carry on hunting the word eyes notice on
his favor
Kelly the hyenas they don't have
predators when they are old when they
are still new after birth they also left
heightened by the dense unattended which
is very much dangerous when it comes to
the predator such as the why dogs wild
dogs when they come to the den they can
eat but when the hyenas are old enough
to defend themselves they don't really
have the data spurt chances of them
being killed by the other predators are
very much high not long time ago we have
seen a big fight between the matriarch
cocky and one of the vocal males just by
the juma den and fortunately Koki
narrowly escaped as that lion was too
big and he was biting a cookie like one
belief
so if you look at our son at the moment
you can see that he's demoralized a
little bit by the hyena which just came
here earlier maybe now he wants the hi
not refers to go away and carry on
hunting so I'm not very far away from
the INA den so shortly I'm gonna go and
make a 10 by the INA day and just to see
what is happening there
as I can see now that asana is is flat
now
is discouraged at the moment so while
they still another vehicle here with me
I'm going to quickly just go make a turn
by the Heiner then come back and carry
on with our son until we see what he is
going to find I just want to show you
something different at the moment so
let's go and see what we can find by the
Heine did
many for neurologic or mala I'm just
talking to the other guys on the other
vehicle in Shangaan asking them to radio
me whenever there's any development here
I will copy the question from MK well
m'kay there is no reason for not liking
the highness Hayden's are very much
beautiful and intelligent animals if I
was to recommend the animal to be
rebranded hyena was going to be the
first one because a lot of people they
do have quite a lot of mythical stories
and superstitious stories about these
lovely animals
so that enemas might be going to the den
as we are not far
so I am not alone
driving at the moment David I swear by
the Maasai Mara he's trying to look for
something interesting for you
well that's exactly what happens with
most of the cats and lipids are not
exceptional when they decide to go flat
that's it not much you can do
we've been following our elephants very
slowly and quietly and one has dragged
behind when all the rest of the heart
has moved on and we'll find out whether
it could be anything wrong with her or
she is just a bit slow because the rests
move in a particular direction and I
don't know how close this boom game will
be for this particular and here let me
just see if we can get a better look for
her what about that is that too close
was it too far just so they can niconico
I'm always excited to hear your name and
when do elephants leap one if this guy
okay now he is moving the bed of speed
to catch up with the rest if they eat to
me like 18 hours in a day niconico
eighteen hours in a day eating all right
she has been able to join the rest of
the hard so they left about six hours in
24 hours day right six hours they have
to drink they have dressed and maybe
they have to get a catnap elephants
niconico in general sleep for a very
short time and this sleep standing they
could go when you know in the middle in
the middle of the heat of the day look
for one huge tree that has some very
good shade and they stay under that tree
and you notice them having some cut naps
occasionally you see the young ones
laying down but it's very funny how they
lay down they lay down with your bellies
not in your bellies per se but only a
side and it's one of the most
comfortable positions I have seen
animals slipping on they look very
uncomfortable when they lay down like
that
that's the rest of the HUD not very
clear but you may just have to move on
and find out what could be ahead of us
so niconico elephants will not sleep
they'll just keep eating and eating and
moving and for reasons just mean jumble
and you know jumbo [ __ ] just mean means
hello the Swahili word for elephant
elephant have to so let me see you are
they gonna give you the easy one it has
to so adjustment I want you to choose
which one you want
one is temple te M Bo and the other one
is Davao and D o vu
so just mean you have a choice of goes
to Temple or noble but apparently
Jasmine temple also means beyond so
hilly is a very rich I would say
language and so Haley is just like
Spanish some Spanish words you might get
one one that might have two different
meanings completely so Timbo is the name
for the elephant but also tempo in
Sohini means BR so you have a choice of
table or oval but just remember if you
decide or you choose temple remember
Tambor also means we are
all right trying to see who else could
be out at this time I should be getting
my readers for clients because what we
do we might choose a sport like like
this all right if you are like both you
can keep both Tim one Davo looks pretty
good
that's pretty good so when we have our
spotlight like this we'll just use it to
the kids game and once we locate it to a
switch the light or the spotlight off
and use infrared I can just smell
something would be happening any time
now because here in the wilderness it's
always a very busy place I would say is
always busy 24 hours
yeah those animals that should be algae
during the day and once they're off from
the stage we have the rust that come in
spotted hyenas a very good example many
people have always thought hyenas are
ugly a signal was saying but is a
misconception hiding us to me do a very
good job they take care of our
environment but also apart from you know
scavenging hyenas also gets their own
food you know the very good hunters and
if asked I'll say hyenas are more
successful than lions and leopards and
cheetahs in terms of getting their own
food
so this particular area we are in we
have a can of highness that you call the
North Krong
and should we see any one or two of them
at the moment that we definitely be
coming from that clan of the Northland
as it
Joyce will be trying to get to the
office and she got two small Cubs and
what's happening she is taking very
close to the with carbs you know in the
Dan and it's very difficult to see her
coming out of the den at night now and
I'm looking at my watch and seeing how
the term will go and most likely I would
want to end up air and sea washes dream
we were with her last night with her two
cubs and when you got the other five
Cubs or together and she was just
playing or keeping them company the
other Cubs and I think their mothers
could have been away either hunting or
looking for food and hyenas being very
territorial or we could have been out
just patrolling their territory making
sure that they don't get how the hyenas
coming to their territory
most predators will be territorial and
what you've noticed predators will
overlap each other we might get Lions
getting into a territory of hyenas or La
Paz God getting the territory of lives
but not to different families of lions
will try to close each other and talking
of highness
Sydney might have arrived at a death
it's got a very big competition between
Sydney and David this afternoon as David
is also looking for his clan and I am
also waiting for the you MacLean to come
out here
so the hider that we saw earlier with
our sauna
it was pokey I have met cookie now now
not very far away from the den she is on
her way back so coming back here we
might have the interesting interactions
between cookie and the little ones
because they have been here earlier
during the day and there were no
Highness here which means little ones
might be coming out for cycling Koki is
not having three cups she's having one
amongst the three because the other two
are for pretty so we might see caucus
least one coming out and pretties as
well coming out and to hang around here
so I'm going to wait because I know that
when the mother comes here the little
ones are gonna come out at this page
it's not looking active but this is an
active den and this is something we must
also expect during the day when the
mothers or the nest is not here it means
the little ones must have to be hiding
there in order to be safe against the
predators
so I can hear some of the Franklin's
they are starting to call maybe she is
getting much closer at the moment and
other ones as well might be also heading
back home so this is not the only thing
we have got but is the active ten at the
moment these Ines they lead us to
different them's dance when they feel
here there's too much parasites such as
fleas they take the little ones the next
step and then when they get there if
they feel that the smell is developing
too much about the presence of the
little ones they move them again they
can be very much nomadic when having the
small cups
sorry I didn't get the question right
but I hear that talking about the
Highness taking the kill or the food
pack so the hyenas are not like dogs
dogs when they go out for hunting
they eat there and they come back to the
nest and vomit to regurgitate food they
have eaten to give to their little ones
- unfortunately
they must have to go there eat and then
they bring the food back home my little
ones are not gonna eat immediately is
for the others to eat so that they can
perform good lactation period a period
of milking these little ones the little
ones will eat when they are we older
than maybe three month is when there
were starts to eat so but so now let's
go through a David who's good the
crocodile at the moment
yes well done Sydney for having gotten
to the high in the den now we got
ourselves a reptile and this is the Nile
crocodile and again remember we are in
infrared now you may be wondering what
am I talking about
took him on a crocodile and you can see
the shiny eye and he may not be able to
see us we see her very well as much as
it's a bit dark it's on the bank of the
Mara River and I'm assuming she's just
enjoying the warmth of the substrate
that's the famous Mara River pretty long
river written about almost 300
kilometres long maybe 200 miles or so
and it originated somewhere in Kenya and
it comes through the Mara triangle it
enters a national park could Serengeti
in Tanzania and then back to the Mara
triangle and it drains in Lake Victoria
and Lake Victoria is the source of the
Nile and maybe this is why this
crocodiles are called the Nile
crocodiles bring some of the largest
crocodiles that you'll see in the world
during the migration will all receive so
many wildebeest and zebra coming
crossing this river here and this
reptiles will always try and cut
something for themselves and being
cold-blooded she might want to stay a
little bit longer just to get a bit of
warmth from that or did you just sleep
she has shut her eyes
excuse me not sure you can hear he posed
in the background there yeah excuse me
I'm pretending to be a hippo I think
there was a most kuda trying to come in
my mouth but I got it out and he was
good well that's a very territorial call
for hippos and most through the males
and any time now that should be coming
out of the water
going out to feed and they're not more
than a hundred meters away from where
this crocodile is so I was slowly to
move forward and so whether we can see
those hippos if Bungay you allow me
we're gonna move forward and who the
expert no this supposed to be out of the
water to go fitting and they might feed
the whole night sometimes they walk 20
30 miles away from the water
and of course that is determined on
availability of food if food is close
and they don't have to go that far if
food is far then they have to do the
same work maybe I'll ever get this suit
here so yeah they walk long and we found
out many people have been hurt or killed
by hippos early in the evening like now
at dusk or dawn because either hippos
are living the water to go and feed and
early in the morning when they're coming
back to the water back home and that's
when maybe the locals of the people in
the village are going to fetch water
either in legs or in rivers
from here I saw Sundberg a me first so
they can support any this sorry my
breakfast kikyo unit o worried about
tonio asking why was the crocodile not
moving in general Crocs out say food
Crocs out say the a bit lazy animals and
just next to it if you got no to the
hippo see you the best we can bond game
next to it is the water and that's where
if anything would go wrong to her she
would very quickly get in the water for
safety and on the edge of the water is
warm as I was saying on the soil there
and she was definitely enjoying the
warmth so she has no reason to leave
some nice warmth and she knows if
anything would go wrong very quickly
she'll jump in the water
most look like what a thickness to me
Holly I was talking of the baths that
you might see at night hours or nature's
water thickness what I'll guess they are
in this kind of darkness
just stay on the edge with water there
for the hippos you move to the right
three Bedouin gay I can only see the
eyes and not the actual hippos if you go
there all those Heights like Bob's just
seeing there those are the hippos in the
water the one that we just had a few
minutes ago and definitely not looking
very clear it should be coming out of
the water now and go and start feeding
and using infrared it doesn't take you
very far
tears from a dream yes is a kind of
creepy to see what we're seeing in the
darkness and that's why at night we are
always very careful because you not know
where the hippo is you don't know where
the crocodile is because a crocodile
could be underwater and still open his
eyes and can see you out on the surface
of the water so we are always very very
careful the croc that we saw earlier was
not very far from this here post so at
night we of course always extra a lot we
take care of what we do watch where you
go and really send very carefully now
we'll just have to move on now because
the hippos are not leaving the waters
yet and find out who could be out of the
water
all right do you go to South Africa to
Sydney and find out what's happening at
the den so now we are heading back to
the cat we have left Illya or sauna s by
the den nothing was happening behind us
who came back there was a maid when I
saw it Elly I thought it was cocky from
a distance but now I saw that it was not
cocky and little ones are still
underground so we then decided to leave
as we were not going to wait for the for
the mothers to come back as we are we
don't know where they are and how far
are they from they dead
so we're just gonna carry on with OSI on
this side and see if he's going to be
successful
it's getting very chilly now here where
we are in the wind is getting cold
I can see that this bush is here they
are much more green and is very thick
this is the area which is consisted of
the green bar bushes
a David unfortunately this side way I am
it doesn't get snow yes some of the past
in South Africa like free stage I have
been there and in 2010 a window in
2015-16 snowing so there are areas which
get snow in South Africa
so let's hope asana is still in here
so these are really wild animals and we
are so relaxed with us because these
animals they learned that we are not a
threat to them so they are doing their
own world business they are doing their
own wild and natural behavior and we are
just viewing them and we don't cause any
harm to them that is why they don't have
to act aggressively towards us but soon
as we start to harm them is when when
they see us they are going to react all
the time
so this is the area where asana might be
hiding at the moment looking for
something
David is having a scrub here at the
moment
well I remember when I was in South
Africa any time we were finishing the
drive the two things we used to look for
scrub has n chameleons and now this has
promised a very sweet memories of a Juma
and the last I remember seen a scrubby
at night was in Juma gasps and that's
the scrub here with a very large years
and big eyes in general you only see
them at night very unusual to see them
during the day way or just in the bushes
unless in the village when we scare them
when we were just walking through the
bushes but in general they come out at
night when it's much cooler and when
maybe they feel much safe and what they
do they'll be digging some roots if you
look at carefully a little there - there
but they tend to dig some roots and
through some grass or some tubas of
course these tubers and roots have lots
of water in them and that's also how
this sauce the water we have seen the
many times once they drop their pool
they eat the same Michelle how are you
and I can promise you 100% Michelle I
don't want to disappoint you I will not
show you a chameleon so please send your
request as usual she'll I'm sure you
know how to do it hashtag safari life
and then it will be sent to my brother
Sydney and give him the pressure so
Michelle I'm getting you a scrub here
please ask my brother to get you a
chameleon in South Africa I don't know
whether Michelle are making sense or not
Boggan do you think I'm making sense -
Michelle yes Michelle I want to tell you
what
abigai the camera protect me - they have
said he has said yes he said yes we'll
give the challenge to Sydney I've
already gotten the
grab here so we share let's give a bit
of pressure to Sydney in and hopefully
gonna get one calcic yes same species of
scrub hair same size same breathing
period same gas station / the same
heavier I would say they're very very
same not much of a difference and you
know coccyx most of one moves him with a
very similar they may vary a little bit
in the coat or maybe in the sizes for
example I'm looking at elephant classic
and I've always the elephant in South
Africa looks a little bit angular and
the elephants in East Africa are more
rounded the impalas for example here a
little bigger I would say and especially
the horns and the ones in South Africa
but ideally they're one and the same
species same genus hello
very you should to see them in pairs
you'll see them 1 1 or when one has a
litter then you'll see them with the
young ones and when I look at the small
animals that I don't think they're good
mothers this is one of them the scrub
hairs do not do a very good job to raise
their young ones looking began was that
a thinker a little bit of careless
mother's drafts so looking big animals
to take care his father so she drops
small lugar is their City a careless
I'll scrub here's look at the size of
that eye is so huge a they need to see
better tonight tray heshes knowing some
tubers that he just dug from the ground
for herself some of the predators of
course any predator do you think of br-2
cheetah hyena Rossellini just got those
words out of my mouth and I was talking
of the predators that go for them they
look very easy to bring down I'll say
wild dogs will bring them down Jack
who's silverback Jacques with
and also other reptiles like snakes and
I'm talking about the Python the pythons
are Smith they move very slowly and
Rosaleen they use the heat receptors to
pick any warmth of an animal and when
these guys just stop plays like that
a Python is very slowly just come and
grab it and just crush it in mouth once
they get supported by they would be
predator so funny they'll always lie
flat and they don't move just like a
stone even when the pressure comes so
close the illustrate imagine the
predator cannot see them I hope you're
not listening to me should be feeding
well keep eating and hopefully Sydney
will not look for a sauna anymore but
look for chameleons for Michelle David
is playing a Robin game it's very much
difficult to find a chameleon at this
stage because he found a scruffy I will
try I will try to take that challenge so
now I'm here with Hassan and right at a
distance of about 250 meters I've got a
head of Impala Oh
feeding coming up much more decide
husana is now acting is sit and wait
predation so at the back we can hear the
the baboons are making some Alam calls
which might then push the impalas to
come closer to asana is you can see the
impalas arena so we just got to be
patient here and see what is going to
happen he is not moving at all
he's at the same position and the wind
is on his favor today
his hunting is determined by the wind
direction
those impalas won't see him he's using
this is more Bush they're right in front
of him and on the right he's using that
small bushes to cover that small green
bush there they won't see him is right
behind that small bush so I'm trying to
check what's happening there by the
impalas somebody can see by looking at
him now you might think he's not he
doesn't want to hunt anymore he's tired
is I can promise you he is going to act
because how he went to that spot way is
now I could see he was crawling and he
went and just lie down there so he's
using that Bush as a cover let's see
slowly
when these impalas are coming and coming
you will see how he's going to act they
are feeding facing this side of the wind
doesn't change direction and alert the
impalas
Elysa
look at that look at that is even now
concentrating this side that side so
he's very much patient I also love this
boy too much oh here comes the hyena
that is what is looking at at this stage
so the chances of this hunt to be
spoiled a high or the chances of the
impalas to run towards the cat while
avoiding the hina they are also very
much high so at least at the moment we
cannot blame the hyena for coming
he where the China is coming from this
impalas but hyenas are so good because
from there I can see the hyena is
looking at the leopard another hyenas
day now now we've got another hyena
again coming to this side to Highness
one is this side another one is here
very close to the cat the one who is
behind the cat is the one who might now
spoil the hunt so now we just going to
cross to the infrared so that we can
give you a better sighting
so you can see now we can see him
clearly by the infrared so the infrared
allows us in order to see these animals
nicely at night during the dark without
the animals as seeing as we are not
using the spotlight animals are in a
complete darkness so now this ayah in
front he is crossing and the impalas are
looking at that China so chances of the
hyenas chances of asana to go for these
impalas
so I'm just assessing here what is going
to happen once I picked up the
possibility of a lovely special
broadcast I am going to invite that
so there a nurse are now moving away and
they don't get surprised from the lights
another vehicle is coming to join us
impalas are still very much relaxed on
the other side so far nothing is
happening what is interesting is the cat
who is now on a concealment so it's good
that the iris did not expose the
leopards
so he's now making sure that the Ines
argon is looking at them they are going
to the den side now we were not lucky
because they were still fire can see
it's only now that they are going back
I've got the names of the two hyenas who
just got passed here and these one of my
viewers suggesting that is Timur and
Kaza
so those impalas are now changing
direction instead of coming this side
they are now moving much more towards
the eastern side can you see that they
are now moving to the eastern side you
can see them there they are moving
towards the eastern side now so it means
there is the inés brought the negative
impact because the leopard change
direction as the inés moved towards this
direction so they did not pass very far
from I know son apologies for that as I
indicated earlier that we are not alone
at the sighting it is another vehicle
nico nico - and the leopard cannot hands
together because that will be a roping
game like what David is doing with the
chameleons because here when they're
hunting together the leopard is gonna
catch and the Ino will take away so that
is the challenge
so the highness are still day they are
not calling and they are still there I
can see we are looking at something high
up one of them is coming back again this
side so this Ayanna's are just hanging
around here they are not leaving he's
looking at them
so they are right here in these bushes
so the chances of asana to carry on
hunting they're very much slim at the
moment if you catch anything to Ines
might give him a problem
so now let's cross over to the Maasai
Mara and get back to David to hear what
is happening at the moment
well I'm sure Sydney will get a
chameleon somehow and it could be
exciting to see hyenas and leopards
hunting together which could be a small
movie like thing to be noticed there's a
lady here in the mara triangle who does
research on titters and we know cheetahs
live or tend to be solitary and if you
see two it should be either a male in a
female when they're meeting or maybe a
mother and her cub Oh a mother and her
two three four cubs but she told me
something very interesting the other day
but for the first time we have seen a
coalition males will be three four five
together that's normal we have Portugal
the Musketeers is a combination of five
male cheetahs in tomorrow but the other
day she told me we have now a fast
record of a coalition of females that
have been together for quite some time
and I cannot wait to see them
I did not doubt her but it sounded a
bits not known to have two female
cheetahs forming a coalition assuming
cheetahs just like layer pods being on
their own being solitary and she told me
yes and she has been following them for
the last six months yes and I mean the
final contused says that's very strange
and again I do not doubt her but I
thought that was rather strange to have
two female cheetahs together and she
told me could be like about now three
months sorry she has been following them
and I'm like oh they be going and she
hasn't seen the last one month she said
but she told me she stayed with him for
three months like every two days every
two days two girls you know it's a long
time for females to be together and it
was not a mother a daughter they're just
two very different Highness
I mean cheetahs so yeah that's rather
strange
so Sydney talking of bloopers hands
together with Highness with something we
have seen them fighting over food
we have seen reports fighting over food
hyenas and hasana
is string or sana is a [ __ ] mobile now
I can see now that the asana is now
lying down relaxed there at the moment
hyenas are giving him problems because
it cannot carry on hunting the impalas
are living on the other side and the
weather is changing the rain is building
we might get some rain here sometime
tonight or tomorrow look at that when we
started it was clear started building
during the drive and now is promising
so you can see that now he's just moving
the ears this what about those -
designers just here and if they are not
giving him chance nothing is going to
happen here so Dias fire and reposition
so that we can see him from the face
general care thank you very very much
for all your support we are hoping for
more rain to come
so this is quite a very nice little
opening we were gonna see a very nice
hand here if the cat was not if a sauna
was not interfered by those highness
normally they can survive for about
fifteen to seventeen years so you can
see that it's quite a lot of years so
but that is a leopard in the world you
can only see the head you can see the
body see the bodies camouflage I can see
that is listening to what is happening
in the surrounding and the wind is still
on his favour so I can be able to
concentrate with eyes closed so when the
eyes closed does not mean it cannot feel
or hear what's happening
you can see that he is not going to
carry on now the way they saw his favor
but the Highness they are giving him
problem he doesn't want to go and hunt
anymore so what I'm going to do now is
to leave him here as I can see that
there will be too many vehicles coming
to join and see if maybe we can find
something interesting around the
Gallagher pen we might be lucky and find
something else
Kathy I have seen the bush babies a lot
and also here in Germany it's quite a
lot of the laser bush babies so we might
be lucky I'm going to have my spotlight
on now and see if we can find some other
animals because I can see that
Isana is now very much relaxed and with
this little bit of time left we might be
lucky and see something interesting
[Laughter]
there is quite a lot of pressure given
by David I'm going to try that but the
chameleons I haven't seen any at the
moment so maybe I'll be lucky who knows
they are here
oh you can see this you can see the
hyena is just now laying down in front
of the vehicle you see right there so
this is showing you that this einar's
are here and they are prepared they are
prepared for whatever comes out for
Salah for tonight to have a share so
they are here to have a share
so now let's quickly go back to David
and see what David is looking for
well Sydney you're not off the hook
you'd need to get a chameleon and I am
sure Michelle is still watching her and
Michelle don't go anywhere until she
gets your chameleon because if he
doesn't then he'll not have much to our
deal and our game was I described here
and he does sorry sorry you okay there
keep going and he was to get communion
what I'm trying to do now is to get so
close to the waffles then almost almost
almost but I don't want it to get it I
want him to do it so Sydney and do it I
have seen one
I thought LLL not stop because I'll make
your life easier and I won't you life to
be difficult today so please just get us
one and you'll make Michelle and
everybody's happy
sorry any loss to them
we really see chameleons here but
sometimes you know with luck yes it
would it would happen this could be the
time to the left there we may have to do
something here em for a few minutes and
it's like now when I'm thinking city to
get the chameleon I might be the one
who'll find it but I might want to do
something before risk for the chameleon
all right you're gonna read your IR
again with the meantime let's go back to
Sydney and give you more pressure for
the chameleon I am still doing the
search year now for something different
and Here I am not winning at the moment
so I'm looking for the bush babies and
the I'm looking for the bush babies and
also the request from David the
chameleon
so the chameleons can be difficult to
see but we can because they do shine in
the eyes and that is how we can see them
the leopard turns there out now I have
seen I have seen two already and this
morning I saw a it was an old dead and
all dead shell for one of the his inch
tortures so but during the winter season
they hide they dig themselves a little
bit in and hide and come out now
so now is the best time to see them they
are around now
a bush babies are hiding tonight when I
don't want them after the game drive
going home is when I see them when I'm
on a game Drive is difficult
now ice is shining here by this pushes
so we will see the bush babies a lot
anytime soon soon as they flying ant
starts to come out we will see them a
lot
so they are very much territorial so
these areas where if we find them today
very often we'll find them at the same
moral at the same area
and child of the universe I think we are
having more or less the same kind of
animals so I'm trying to think about a
different animal which is not occurring
to the morrow that we are having here
and I'm finding it very much difficult
so I'm gonna have to check with my other
colleagues who has been to the Mara who
knows exactly what was occurring day
when I come back again here tomorrow
maybe I will be telling you which
animals we have which are active at
night which are not occurring in Mara so
I can smell the elephants here in this
area so the elephants you can easily
smell them just from the Buddha scent so
here I can smell this a very strong
scent coming from the northern side
so now let's cross over to david by the
masai mara and see if he's winning with
the nocturnal animals well Sydney you
can smell anything you want to smell but
I'll only be happy if you smell a
chameleon what animals could we see here
that we not see in the Mara I do not
know but we got a hyena
because we have arrived at the waffles
then and that is worth was herself and
if you carefully
she got a collar on her neck and she is
the commander-in-chief of the North clan
of highness let's Harden but in lieu
carefully she doesn't seem to be fitting
in the den because the dens are meant to
be small just take this Cubs in and
protect them from would-be predators see
them coming in the North clan has about
70 plus hyenas all together and all
these juniors
then the caps I mean I'll tell you Lee
you like to know how long they can
survive without nourishment I wouldn't
say it dude survived for a long time in
general most Cubs of cannibals are wind
very early but the hyenas and most of
the spotted hyenas will keep noting
their cubs for almost one and a half
years and to me that's a very long time
to keep you know nothing in their cubs
so I would say if they're not nourished
very well chances for them for survival
out zero they would not survive
they are telefax do not survive the
hyenas take a very long time nourishing
via Cubs I mean those that eating meat
very early even at the age of three
months you'll get Heiner Cubs eating
meat and all of them on the bone and
they're born with erupted teeth they got
the currents they got a scissors you
know in place as they're born and
us-ally I would say what in twelve weeks
or so they'll be able to start eating
meat but then ask for very long time so
if they will not have say for example
their mothers or auntie's or anybody
else to get the meat and definitely they
will not be able to hunt for themselves
out maybe guess they'll have no chance
of survival this has spotted highness we
got three types of highness or species
of hyenas in Africa this control hyenas
and the strip's highness
straw hat election or the hyenas can
recognize leaders of different clans and
I would say yes because and the leaders
will always carry themselves in a
particular way but more from the north
they made sure they do not criss-cross
or overlap the boundaries so for example
where we are sitting now this is the
territory of the North clan and the
female you see there in the den that is
to office
that's Hallam and they'll always try and
keep in their territory and not going in
other territories we have seen once in
awhile for example if a Hina here
because the old is hunt for themselves
should one of them decide to go and hunt
and she's a prey call it a zebra for
example and chase it and zebra enters in
a different territory which is not part
of the territory the predator the chaser
would stop at that point it's like a
dead stop simply because she doesn't
want to get into trouble by going in a
different territory but just to ask your
question yes they'll tell because the
leaders killed himself in a particular
way one was here because hyenas are very
much Sri Akal we just found out waffles
here did not come out through the
lineage is something moving on the right
there
hopefully her calves will come out at
one point
child of the universe what would happen
if two kinds of hyenas fight over title
that has been seen once in the oil but
that would only happen if they meet I'd
see a feeding site and we are trying to
you know snatch or steal from food from
each other that's the only time you get
hyenas fighting but the bigger clan in
general will win not very far from where
we are there's another clan that could
happy is zebra plan and they're not as
many in numbers are this and the one or
two few times we have seen them having a
conflict the north clan always win this
morning we saw a predator Lions that you
call or we know had made a kill and we
had the harpies of Rockland very close
to them and this sat there for over an
hour and they did not get anywhere close
to them if the Lions or the you know you
know pretty Lions would go and hunt as
we turn try to find out what's moving so
close to me oh very good
Thank You Bungay if no hunt I'll tell
you the north plan are very aggressive
and the laura's get the food from the
Lions so of course if the would win out
say the winner would be determined by
the number in the clan not sure how many
are in the harpy's zebra clan but in the
north clan we have known because you're
following for quite some time they're
over 70 of them yesterday the Cubs came
out of the den and they're very playful
it's a bit cold for them Oh as you have
seen waffles were just like staying on
the door on the entrance making sure
maybe they don't come out it's just so
quiet and pitch black it's the two
hyenas moving there I don't know what
they want to do but all these are
youngsters
and I'm just hoping these cabs will come
out but now can we give Sydney last or
one more pressure for the chameleon
please I am still here struggling to
find the small nocturnal animals such as
the bush babies and the chameleons and I
know a lot of you must be asking
themselves such as
questions such as why are we not on s
ABC 3 tonight this is due to the Muslims
a super league cricket we will be with
you again on s ABC 3 6:30 p.m. as from
the 23rd of December 2018
I'm trying to go and check around the
Calico pain area maybe we might be lucky
here but the wind is blowing too much
I can't hear even if there's a lion roar
this wind is blowing too much so now
that the wind is blowing my yes and I
can hear
let me rather take you back to David
maybe is quiet by the Maasai Mara sorry
Sydney for too much wind but I hope that
is not an excuse to get a chameleon but
just look at how steel the air is here
those leaves or bushes near the den of
waffles they're not even moving
but alia the wind was very strong but
things have slowed down now all those
hyenas that you see they're just showing
submission to office office is the one
in that den and and you're saying what
was fought our way through up to the
ladder and I was saying I Nina's very
much real calm and if you're born from a
high-ranking female and you're born a
female cub you get the same status but
waffles force hurry up there she
currently got two cubs which I think she
have instructed them to stay in they're
not come out for return she knows better
and if one of them turns out to be a
female she'll be of course getting same
ranking or very high status just like
the mother so hyenas are just like
elephants where they are led by females
trying to sleep on that one
this has been a very great afternoon but
we may apologize for having started
rather late in the morrow triangle we
had a bit of technical issues and also
we lost Steve over at one point when he
developed some technical issues with
this camera so things that will always
happen once in oil but I think me as
Sydney have been able to pull through
and ending the drive with a Highness I
think it's pretty special
having seen husana as much as I would
see as Sydney has let me down by not
sporting a chameleon me having done my
bit harvests in a scrub here we want to
say or thank everybody for having been
with us on behalf of Sydney Steve Oval
and myself and camera operators we thank
you all very much
join us tomorrow morning and goodbye